yo theo yo brandon what's up
uh ian brown here i'm in austin texas
delivering pizza actually
at my job um originally from houston
texas
what's up gang gang h-town baby
so this [ __ ] here just took me two
dollars
83 cents on a 40 ticket um i want to
know what you guys think
um about tipping over 20
do you do it is it too much do you not
uh my opinion is you should always tip
over 20
um i also want to know what cat thinks
about my hair is it too long do i have a
chance
[Laughter]
for the girls i don't know tell me what
to do
love you guys game game buzz buzz is it
how what do you think of his haircat
he has beautiful hair is it too long
though uh
it is a little long but i don't really
mind it he just has really nice hair
he's a regular man this guy yeah how
tall is amanda
say his height nick he didn't say his
head
now as far as tipping i believe in over
20 percent if they do the job sometimes
postmates like your food's on its way
and like oh sorry you have to do another
delivery yeah
and whatever you order is gonna come 30
minutes later i'm like oh you just
[ __ ] up you ain't getting your tip now
yeah
and sometimes it'll be like hunt it'll
be like honduras on his way you know and
then it'll be like
hondura has measles you know yeah loses
three days and then it's like oh hondura
has dysentery they have
we have to bury somebody in his group
and you're like is this oregon trail
i thought this was postmates and this is
have you ever had it to where
it tells you what car they're coming in
yep and then they show up on a bike
yeah yeah bruh i'm like how does that
happen they had a fella that came to me
one night dude and he's like man i gotta
come chill out man can i come in i gotta
go
[Laughter]
did he come in and chill out no no no i
went because i got him a cup of water
and told him just leave the cup i mean i
respect his hustle and stuff but
yeah he was on a uh he was on a
bird on a bird scooter and it took
forever
no if it takes too long i know it's up
the stream like you're [ __ ] man
i can't give you a good tip i can't give
you get if it if you're bullshitting
can't give you a good tip man
dude i'll tip this guy do we have this
guy's information nick
yes i'm gonna send him a hundred bucks
let me send my hundred dollars oh nice
nice
i'll se i'll throw that in there too
damn chappelle
salary i
like to tip well i like yeah me too if
they're good but
i'm just not doing for everyone if
you're shitty you ain't getting that
salty tip
i'll tell you i'll tip 200. i'll i'll do
you i'll oh
one of them i went up in you i'm just
saying i will do your hundred
you keep your money ah
so chappelle
[Laughter]
you were doing it to be kind man so yeah
wow theophy was generous to chappelle
ever since he said he was a pretty crier
last week
bill's trying to [ __ ]
it was weird basically so i'm paying you
a hundred dollars not to try to
this episode is disgusting
this is disgusting
[Music]
is